[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur lcp et
public sénat 50 millions de français
sont vaccinés c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce que sur le front du coc vide la
france va mieux du coup le pouvoir
d'achat et la sécurité se disputent la
une de l'actualité de cette rentrée pour
prévenir la grogne sur les fins de mois
difficiles le président macron a
augmenté le chèque énergie l'opposition
promet elle d'augmenter les salaires la
campagne largement lancé à quelques mois
de la présidentielle sauf que chez l air
les républicains le choix du candidat à
la présidentielle est précisément un peu
laborieux et eric zemmour en profite
pour jouer les chants boul'tout
bienvenue dans audition publique
l'émission politique hebdomadaire
commune lcp public sénat une heure un
invité pour entamer la saison nous
accueillons le président du sénat
bonjour au revoir merci beaucoup soir à
tous les trois une route pour trouver
pensant à tous les trois et ça nous en
compagnie de brigitte boucher lcp steve
jourdain de public sénat vous les
connaissez bien sûr d'ailleurs dans un
instant ils vont vous interroger sur l'
annonce du président macro concernant
les harkis c'est une journée importante
pour remettre à bord gérard larcher la
crise diplomatique qui a éclaté vendredi
après la rupture du contrat du siècle
rupture par une alliance américano
australo britannique
pour résumer on n'a pas encore entendu
le président macro sur ce sujet d'abord
est ce que ça vous surprend dans sa
matière rouge mais au fond ce ça traduit
notre éviction
da des enjeux les plus importants les
plus tendus du monde c'est l'accès au
pacifique et nous voyons bien que la
confrontation entre les etats-unis et la
chine va se jouer et on n'a pas souhaité
que la france yeux ils soient présentes
et pourtant la france est présent dans
le pacifique en nouvelle-calédonie
elle est présente à wallis et futuna les
présentes au polynésie française
deuxième chose que ça appelle c'est bien
sûr on n'a pas entendu le président ma
grange est pas beaucoup entendu les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
européens et j'essaie de d'écouté de
scruter je n'entends rien madame van de
wiele émettant alors pour
défendre la france mais il était temps
il était temps parce que le sujet
maintenant c'est concrètement à quelques
mois de la présidence française
la conférence de sécurité et de défense
sa seule manière d'être présent c'est
une europe forte et une europe forte qui
assume ses responsabilités c'est une
défense commune alors mais c'est
allons par étapes
quand nous voyons nous avons encore des
interrogations sur le scaf sur l'avion
aujourd'hui je crois que ce qui s'est
passé en afghanistan et aujourd'hui ce
qui vient de se passer appel à véritable
sursaut de l'europe en matière de
sécurité et de pardon à court terme
avant d'en lien sur ce que pourrait
faire le président macron quand il sera
président européenne en janvier
qu'est-ce qu'on peut exiger de nos
alliés pour l'instant on a rappelé nos
ambassadeurs symboliquement
diplomatiquement c'est très fort mais
qu'est ce qu'on peut demander plus que
vous voudriez
naturellement les états unis nous sommes
alliés mais des alliés ça se respecte et
manifestement il n'y a pas eu de respect
vis-à-vis de la france je partage cette
décision mais qu' une décision de court
terme symbolique mais elle doit nous
réveiller et réveiller devrait sortir de
l'eau tant attendu
c'est un sujet qu'on ne prête pas comme
ça au revers d'un soir l'otan c'est une
structure que nous avons réintégré
j'ai d'ailleurs voté cette réintégration
à l'époque sur la proposition du
président de chirac ce n'est pas une
décision qu'on prend comme cela certains
jouets c'est l'occasion
c'est l'occasion entre alliés européens
n'ont pas dénoncé l'autre mais de se
dire que ensemble on pèsera ce que je
constate c'est que l'europe et la france
sont évincés de cet enjeu majeur quels
axes indo pacifique ont toutes dernières
questions quand même pas
respirer
on va se poser les questions ça va être
le rôle du contrôle parlementaire et
contrôle parlementaire la commission de
la défense des affaires étrangères de la
défense me demandiez comment savoir
demande le président quand bombe déjà
proposé une commission attend sens
donnons à nos sommes d'audition
certaines public certaines à huis clos
avec la ministre de la défense des
services extérieurs il faut qu'on sache
pourquoi on n'a pas perçu en fait ce qui
était en train de se préparer on
traînait aussi les conséquences pour
l'industrie de défense et conséquences
en matière d'emploi en matière de
recherche tout cela nous devons
l'évaluer et nous allons le faire c'est
le rôle de contrôle du parlement merci
l'actualité du jour cette annonce
importante des manuels macron pour un
projet de loi de reconnaissance et de
réparation pour les parkings l'écoutent
la france a des devoirs à l'égard de
ceux qui la servent et la défendent
les harkis ont été ont toujours été et
sont des français
par le sang versé les combats choisi et
leur naissance à chaque fois
après la guerre d'algérie
la france a manqué à ses devoirs envers
les harkis leurs femmes leurs enfants
bougent et le cocher oui gérard larcher
outre le projet de loi de reconnaissance
et de réparation emmanuel macron aussi
demandé pardon aux harkis il a eu raison
de faire ça coûtait
le dossier est requis c'est une tache
dans notre histoire font notre pays n'a
pas donné aux femmes et aux hommes qui
avaient fait confiance en la france qui
l'avait choisie tout simplement la
reconnaissance
déjà en 2005 jacques chirac jacques
chirac avait entamé au travers d'un
projet de loi cette reconnaissance cette
reconnaissance avec une dimension
financière sans doute insuffisant mais
cette reconnaissance la place et du rôle
qu'ils avaient joué nos compatriotes à
partie dans l'accompagnement de notre
pays à un moment très difficile et de
tension
celui qui a parlé de reconnaissance
c'est nicolas sarkozy en 2012 ne
l'oublions pas et c'est nicolas sarkozy
qui au fond a dit moi je suis comme lui
je préfère la reconnaissance à la
repentance la reconnaissance aujourd'hui
elle doit continuer à se traduire par un
certain nombre de soutiens et il avait
fait ce discours nicolas sarkozy dans ce
qui était une des tâches camp de
rivesaltes
car pour bien connaître quelques
familles qui ont vécu dans ces camps et
notamment une personnalité éminente
aujourd'hui qui sert la république pour
lequel j'ai un immense respect et qui a
été à mon cabinet je n'en dirai
naissance et pas de repentance à parce
que je prouve que leur reconnaissance
c'est ce qu'attendent justement
là-dessus pro patria je compris qu'on
sait propos sur la côte et
[Applaudissements]
2017 g est-ce qu'il sort de l'ambiguïté
là et maniema j'espère que c'est pas dur
en même temps je pense que aujourd'hui
il faut reconnaître la meilleure qui ça
ne veut pas dire que nous n'avons pas
avec l'algérie des relations algérie qui
traversent des moments difficiles vous
savez le sénat des relations avec le
conseil de la nation je souhaite que
nous ayons mais ça n'est pas sans la
reconnaissance de la place si
particulière si douloureuse et trop
longtemps oubliées des harkis on a
changé de sujet on va parler un peu de
sanitaires vous aviez rendez vous cher à
l'archet avec jean castex aujourd'hui à
matignon vous avez notamment parlé de la
crise sanitaire évidemment à l'ordre du
jour il ya un projet de loi
qui sera présenté le 13 octobre en
conseil des ministres et ce projet de
loi il vise à prolonger le pass
sanitaire ma question est simple est-ce
qu'il faut oui ou non prolonger le pass
sanitaires d'abord la crise sanitaire
n'est pas terminée à cet instant je
pense à nos compatriotes encore
dans les antilles en guyane nous avons
évoqué la situation notamment dans les
antilles et notamment en guyane en
nouvelle calédonie et dans lequel
le gouvernement va envoyer des renforts
médicaux j'ai une haute ce soir sur ce
sujet ne l'oublions pas est sur le pas
soyons solidaires
seconde des choses nous avons voté
majoritairement le pass solitaire et
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
cet après midi avec le premier nous
avons fait un bilan de cette obligation
vaccinale notamment sur les soignants et
constater que hormis hormis dans
certains outre-mer les choses ont très
très largement progressé de la méthode
oui parce que mais nous l'avons voté
parce que passer ni terry obligations
c'était une nécessité
alors est-ce qu'il faut prolonger se
passent très long terme maintenant
savoir rendez-vous savoir rendez vous
qu'est le 15 novembre et en fonction de
la situation
le gouvernement va consulter le
parlement le parlement dont la mission
est de voter
l'éventualité de prolonger le pass
sanitaire de quelle manière
aujourd'hui le territoire et pour quelle
durée
voilà les trois cents enfants préférant
écouter je vais m'entretenir avec les
présidents de groupe et demain je vais
m'entretenir avec le président de la
commission des lois et le rapporteur qui
est filée bas je pense que la réaction
au sénat va être en matière de méthodes
de dire le pas solitaire c'est un outil
utile mais qui doit toujours être l'
équilibre entre les libertés et la
sécurité venaient pas hostile à ce qu
ils seront logés au delà du 15 novembre
on comprend bien la même chose à tous y
découvre des la même chose la deuxième
des choses c'est
est-ce qui s'applique de manière
uniforme sur le territoire s'est
éventrée territorialisation ta sujet qui
mérite vraiment d'être analysée et on
voit bien qu'il ya des réponses
territoriale
favorable justement la science j'ai
abordé le sujet territoriale ça fera
partie des débats le sujet c'est le
délai
est ce que on enjambe une longue période
ou prétexte qu'on a des élections
présidentielles il ya deux hypothèses
fin mars fin juillet jusqu'à fin jusqu'à
fin juin seulement l'hypothèse pour nous
c'est le contrôle régulier du parlement
il nous reste avant le 15 novembre
quand même assez étonnant c'est demain
non je pas de mal prénom pardonnez-moi
55 jours donc on a du temps et nous
avons vécu
une période plus courte depuis la mise
en place du pass sanitaires donc la
question c'est le contrôle parlement par
le parlement il y aura des débats et que
le sénat très sensible contrôle
parlementaire très sensible à cet
équilibre permanent est nette entre ses
cuisses
est une rolls débat je pense que nous
arriverons à un moment à converger
répète la question vous n'êtes pas
favorable à bonjour est ce qu'on en
jambes ils ont été la position du sénat
ça n'est pas ma position le parlement je
le rappelle fini ses travaux en février
mais il reste toujours un parlement on
parle bien évidemment on peut le
convoqué en session extraordinaire c'est
ce
que nous avons fait il y a deux semaines
pour
un joue trop bien alors on avance sur
l'économie avec je le disais tout à
l'heure un pouvoir d'achat qui préoccupe
les français le gouvernement s'est
activement parce que les prix de
l'énergie flandes lisabeth que ce soit
sur le gaz l'essence bientôt
l'électricité nous annoncer que choisir
le gouvernement a annoncé la semaine
dernière une augmentation du chèque
énergie 200 euros pour les 5 millions
8,2 bénéficiaires est-ce que c'était la
bonne décision à prendre côté d'abord
les français ont le sentiment
que leur pouvoir d'achat
abc ils sont plus de 55%
et en même temps les statisticiens et je
pense qu'il nous dit aussi la vérité
constate plutôt un pouvoir d'achat aux
mois qui a été stable qui a même
légèrement augmenté
en même temps les français on sur
épargne et 160 milliards parce que cette
crise des inquiète continue à les
inquiéter pour leur avenir c'est donc un
mélange de réalité et d'inquiétudes par
contre sur la question de l'énergie
la question de l'énergie nous renvoie de
choses la crise des gilet jaune
souvenez-vous augmentation de l'énergie
de la vie quotidienne notamment du
carburant pour un motif rien à tirer les
le président en augmentant justement
très rapidement ce chèque et n'a remis
le sujet quand nous avons eu la loi
climat résilience nous avons dit
attention à toutes ses décisions sur les
conséquences et puis ça nous renvoie un
troisième sujet
parce que l'énergie c'est un facteur
important pour le voir de shell pour la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et ça
renvoie au débat sur la place de
l'électronucléaire et au fait que la
commission vous évoquez la réaction
positive une main de van der leyen il ya
très peu de jours a considéré que
l'énergie nucléaire n'entrait pas dans
le plan de relance vers de l'europe
après son
majeur sur lequel on pourra pas faire
toujours dû en même temps faudra que qu
à temps choisi six nations du chèque
énergie
je vais pas sur l'énergie c'est une
c'est une réponse aujourd'hui pour les 5
millions six cent mille français qui en
ont le plus besoin d'amis avons tant
mieux mais vous voyez bien que ça ne
résout pas le problème sur le fond
beaucoup
enfin le gouvernement débloque donc cl
il ya aussi une hausse du smic qui est
évoqué à skis emmanuel macron est en
train et bien tout simplement de cramer
la caisse comme on dit à quelques mois
de la présidentielle maintenant bas
d'abord ça nous renvoie en quoi qu'il en
coûte le quoi qu'il en coûte ça a été
une décision utile pour soutenir les
françaises et les français pour soutenir
notre économie pour soutenir un certain
nombre d'activités qui étaient
totalement
empêché mais il va falloir que le quoi
qu'il en coûte ce ne soit pas un mode de
vie
ça devient quoi qu'il advienne la
situation aujourd'hui avait quand même
des réalités financières
extrêmement forte nous avons un déficit
budgétaire qui est des 120 milliards
d'euros exposé nous avons une dette qui
va approcher les 3000 et milliards
d'euros et on continue à dépenser nous
allons avoir le les éléments du projet
de loi de finances
la cre a dit ouais mais on d'ores et
déjà qu'il ya plus 11 milliards c'est à
dire que nous ne sommes pas revenus à
une trajectoire vertueuse de la dépense
publique et en plus on l'a abandonné
tout ce qui pouvait à terme générer des
recettes sur la dépense publique mais je
vais prendre la question de la réforme
des retraites chacun sait que c'est un
des éléments majeurs du retour
progressif à un équilibre financier
doit
rentrer dans une campagne électorale où
on distribue son rôle sur ce projet sur
son projet de loi de finances et
de financement de la sécurité sociale
d'ailleurs cet après midi que le premier
ministre puisque d'évoquer la rencontre
avec le premier ministre nous avons
parlé des mesures éventuellement sur la
dépendance qui pourraient dans ce texte
du projet de loi de sécurité
sociale
encore faut-il ne pas faire imploser la
caisse
qu'il advienne
la question de style jardin portait sur
les cadeaux de noël que certains voient
distribuer
tous extrêmement responsables dans ces
labels ne pas continuer à mener notre
pays c'était nécessaire je rappelle le
quoi qu'il en coûte aujourd'hui elle
n'est plus aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
rentre vers le retour à la situation
antérieure générations à venir est
évalué le match on est en campagne
électorale oui je crois enfin j'ai cru
percevoir
mais je suis un peu naïf peut-être
charles h et vous dites qu'il faut faire
attention à la dépense publique et à
droite vous êtes soucieux justement des
deniers de l'état valérie pécresse qui
est dans votre camp dont vous êtes
proche propose d'augmenter les salaires
de 10% les salaires nets est ce que ça
vous semble réaliste au moment où
justement dit qu'il faut faire des
vagues j'ajoute un chiffre dans la
dépense publique en trois ans avant que
vides alors que le président de la
république s'était engagé à maîtriser
puis à réduire la dépense publique on a
fait + 80 milliards mais le déficit
était revenu à 3% we have an avant le
candidat avant le vide aujourd'hui il ya
un débat autour du pouvoir d'achat les
propositions de valérie pécresse et
d'autres candidats nous renvoie la
question du pouvoir d'achat qu'elle
propose de financer par la réduction
d'autres dépenses publiques des charges
on a en fait un vrai sujet sur le
pouvoir d'achat et le salaire les
charges et les impôts nous restons un
pays extrêmement fiscalisés voilà
pourquoi personnellement c'est
extrêmement prudent j'étais ministre du
travail sur cette question du pouvoir
d'achat c'est un sujet important qui
doit faire débat mais qui ne peut pas
conduire à des propositions qui ne sont
pas calculés surenchère celle là
peut-être parce que j'ai avalé la
proposition de valérie pécresse et nous
allons en reparler ensemble il faut
vraiment que ce soit avec eux sigma égal
zéro la fin il faut faire attention on
va parler de la sécurité c'est très
important steve emmanuel macron annoncé
la création d'une instance de contrôle
parlementaire oui une instance de
contrôle parlementaire pour contrôler
les forces de police vous y êtes
favorable personnellement bon bout et de
sécurité chs a été fait pourquoi
pour faire face aux grands échecs du
quinquennat tél la montée de
l'insécurité
la réalité de la montée de l'insécurité
quand on voit un certain nombre de
chiffres et je vais pas vous abreuver de
chiffres mais violence par exemple plus
20% donc la réponse c'est d'abord de
faire confiance et donner des moyens à
la police à la gendarmerie et ensuite à
la justice pour répondre
un système pénitentiaire qui a besoin
d'être revêtir cette instance dont on a
attendu quatre ans pour le faire au
sénat nous avons voté un certain sur les
moyens sur les effectifs et aujourd'hui
il ya des choses intéressantes dans les
propositions des macros la formation
caméra piétons
la manière dont évoluent les carrières
l'organisation territoriale je note que
d'ailleurs c'était dans deux rapports du
sénat celui de françois grosdidier et
michel boutant et celui rémy pointereau
donc on va pas bouder cela mais sur cf
maintenant sur la question pardonnez moi
si on n'a retenu que cela n'en nubo vous
d'accord elle me concerne mais pardonnez
moi la sécurité les français ne le
concernent et c'est pour moi une
priorité
le contrôle aujourd'hui d'abord il faut
pas jeter l'opprobre sur un corps de
police et de gendarmerie dans l'immense
majorité de ceux qui assurent notre
sécurité
sont respectueux de l'état de droit et
des valeurs que véhicule la république
et quand on regarde ces 7% vous le savez
aujourd'hui des fonctionnaires 6 55% des
contrôles
nous pouvons toujours contrôler quand il
ya eu le rapport grosdidier en 2018
c'est un travail de contrôle du sénat ce
candidat je pense une nouvelle instance
le président je retrouverai tout à
l'heure le président de la commission
des lois précises ce qu'il attend de
cette délégation ont pour lens par
exemple une délégation renseignement qui
fonctionne mais payant partagé entre
l'assemblée nationale sénat
oui mais il ya une commission des lois
s'est véritablement mais non bien il
faut faire la même chose puisque je vous
rapporte que les rapports du gipn sont
publiés d'ailleurs donc il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui une absence de transparence
donc il faut qu'on nous précise les
choses
je prends l'exemple de la belgique la
belgique a elle a mis en place une forme
de commissions de contrôle mais qui est
désigné par les deux chambres et qui
travaille en transparence c'est aussi
une réflexion et un débat qu'on peut
avoir
pourquoi pas on verra ce qu'on fait deux
ans qu'on y met dedans et pardonnez-moi
va pas demander l'autorisation on va pas
demander nous le parlement
l'autorisation de contrôler la police et
la gendarmerie c'est un droit
constitutionnel
voilà donc finalement ça sera peut-être
super fait écouter il n'est pas superflu
de faire respecter l'état de droit mais
pardonnez moi c'est aussi une décision
que prendront les parlementaires merci
infiniment métier de boucher estime
jourdain d'avoir posé toutes ces
questions j'ai au président larcher on
va tout de suite s'orienter vers le
figaro notre partenaire le fier ou le
figaro live vincent roux bonsoir chers
vincent
qu'est ce qui mobilise les lecteurs et
qui justifier une question président
larcher
alors ce qui a mobilisé les lecteurs est
en tout cas les lecteurs du figaro ce
week-end c'est la mobilisation des la
mobilisation des chasseurs et qui a été
remarquée avec notamment la mobilisation
également de xavier bertrand qui est
allée manifester à amiens ce matin
julien bayou a réagi avec beaucoup de
virulence il a notamment déclaré chez le
confrère de france info ce qu'on nous
présente comme une activité rurale il
parle de la chasse c'est une fête news
complète parce que la chasse est
aujourd'hui un hobby de citadins de
cadres csp + et la majorité des ruraux
les vrais et au ps est opposée à la
chasse parce que c'est une nuisance sans
fin quel est votre quel est votre avis
gérard larcher il était jeune il a
partagé avec moi
ce qu'est la vie d'une société communale
de chasse dans un certain nombre de
territoires notamment dans un
département comme le cantal c'est ce qui
reste vraiment vivant dans le bout du
territoire de la vie associative
vraiment julien bayou n'a pas compris
que quelque part c'est un mode de vie
c'est une ruralité vivante une ruralité
qui partage qui se rend compte et qui
prend soin du territoire beaucoup plus
qu'on ne l'imaginent qui est aujourd'hui
plan d'aidé qui aujourd'hui pratique de
nettoyage de la nature qui aujourd'hui
protège d'un certain nombre de
populations qui aujourd'hui c'est mal
certain nombre de cultures favorables à
des reproductions je pense à l'outarde
canepetière c'est peut-être que julien
bayou ce que c'est parce que c'est que
l'outarde canepetière
je vous expliquerai cabane en camargue
c'est une petite oie très particulière
eh bien je dois dire qu'il est temps
qu'on met au ban de notre société cette
ruralité là ça fait partie des fractures
de notre pays des fractures entre les
français moi je peux comprendre qu'on
n'aime pas la chasse qu'on n'en partage
pas mais je pense que nous devons
dialoguer nous devons partager
comprendre au fond il faut nous écouter
les uns les autres et ça nous renvoie
ses presque évangélique ce que je suis
en train de dire mais ça nous renvoie à
ma conception de la société une société
où on bannit le rejet des uns par
rapport aux autres et je dois dire que
j'ai partagé je n'ai pas manifester ça
n'est pas le rôle du président du sénat
mais je me suis senti très solidaire de
mon président de fédération celle d'île
de france qui fait un travail ondes
écologique extraordinaire et qui était
amiens et bien en voilà merci beaucoup
pour cette question qui a beaucoup
inspiré
le président larcher on vous retrouve
tout à l'heure vincent euros pour
d'autres questions des lecteurs du
figaro et en retient votre invitation à
julien bayou moi je n'ai rien à l'art et
lui montrer ce que c'est qu'un bédard et
le chien las vegas est pas là et c'est
quelque chose de particulier pour vous
la condamnation de la chasse par
certains écologie ça traduit finalement
ça renvoie cet archipel isation et à ses
13 ans quand il avait 2 martichoux par
cette fracture cette fracture de notre
pays elle et territoriales et sociales
et les communautaires et nous avons du
mal de plus en plus à former communauté
nationale j'ai répondu à des jeunes à
l'occasion des journées du patrimoine
non mais ils mendient
expliqué nous pour qu'on doit être
attaché à la france bien ce genre de
réaction ça des tâches une partie de
leur amour pour la france alors en face
aux istréens vous l'avez reconnu
éditorialistes est directeur adjoint du
figaro pour des questions on va dire
plus politique parce qu'il se passe des
choses en attaque
on soir elisabeth anciens soir gérard
larcher
[Musique]
vous dites que vous êtes inquiet sur les
fractures si vous n'êtes pas un peu
inquiet sur l'avenir quand même de votre
parti républicain on connaît maintenant
quasiment tous les candidats à la
présidentielle même ceux qui ne sont pas
encore déclarés mais qui font peu de
doute vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
notamment le président de la république
et vous la droite la droite républicaine
et bien ça traîne on comprend rien
autant c'était clair yacks et à 5 ans
quand vous aviez des primaires ouvertes
autant là on comprend plus rien comment
vous allez procéder les quartiers non il
traite le sujet pour nous les
républicains et nos amis les familles
centristes
c'est comment le premier parti du
territoire
premier parti au pluriel du territoire a
rien gagné nous avons gagné les
municipales les sénatoriales les
régionales et départementales
comment on redevient le première les
premières formations politiques
nationales pour proposer une alternance
au pays et que on ne soit pas dans le
remake c'est du vieux français du
terroir de du second tour de 2017 entre
emmanuel macron et et marine le pen
alors nous allons suivre une procédure
reconnaît que ça prend un peu de temps
je reconnais mais le président de ma
formation politique décidé que ce serait
un vote il l'a toujours dit je partage
cette deuxième type de vote alors mode
demain il ya monsieur jean leonetti le
maire d'antibes qui doit remettre un
rapport pour justement proposé une
méthode laquelle ça sera on croit savoir
mon petit doigt me dit que ça pourrait
être une primaire quand même
semi-ouverte ça veut dire quoi
d'ailleurs le vote aura lieu devant le
congrès ce sera samedi ce week-end et
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour dire aux
militants de la famille des républicains
ne pas oublier d'exprimer leur choix
samedi prochain drive présent extrême
non pour des raisons évidentes au
période de pandémie le scrutin sera
électronique et je les appelle vraiment
à voter en fête durera de choix n'en
voir à quoi aura deux choix premier du
choix c'est que vous avez qualifié
de primaire se veut ouverte c'est-à-dire
un corps électoral il sera naturellement
les adhérents des républicains des
familles politiques associés et puis
ceux qui se reconnaissent dans les
valeurs de la droite et du centre mais
qui devront accepter de quitter
l'anonymat d'accord ils devront accepter
ici d'une charte et avoir leur nom et
avoir leur nom publié et donc à partir
de ce moment là eh bien on choisira
entre les camps bien formés deuxième
formule la seconde formule qui est
proposé est une formule elle qui
s'adresse aux adhérents des républicains
que nous souhaitons et je souhaite
qu'elle soit ouverte aux autres familles
politiques
de la droite et du centre j'allais dire
les clients les amis de monsieur hervé
morin lui dis parce que nous avons des
accords politiques avec une réflexion ce
qu'on louvre des formations
aujourd'hui ça fait à peu près 120 mille
cent vingt-cinq mille
accord électoral d'accord et derrière ça
mais il ya une réalité c'est qu'il y
aura une compétition
et que celui ou celle qui dépose sa
candidature devra s'engager à la loyauté
et devra s'engager à accepter la
décision il sera pris soin dans ce que
vous appelez la primaire celui ouvertes
soit dans le vôtre formule étant selon
la formule brouillage choix formule qui
sera choisi samedi on l'a compris ce
week-end on aura le résultat samedi soir
oui et une fois que cette formule sera
choisie comme elle elle sera mis en
oeuvre en application alors l'objectif
c'est que fin novembre où tout début des
112 ion ou une candidate avant de nous
sommes oui au tout début décembre que
nous soutiendrons tous autour d'un
projet qui sur la rencontre à la fois du
projet du candidat et du projet
notamment des républicains qui a été
présenté aux universités américaines
âgées bertrand que vous avez vu
récemment se rangera il a bu il a besoin
comme les autres et à airvault du
soutien notre parti je vais vous dire je
les ai tous vus tous se rencontrer et
pas simplement dans un dîner force un
peu piège dans une manade ils ont tous
le sens de la responsabilité si nous
avons
deux candidats c'est même pas la peine
de faire et on va je j'ai confiance
g en tous les cas la ferme volonté je
crois que ce sera le cas vous avez
l'accord de xavier bertrand pour ça que
je demande pas son accord ou son
désaccord c'est le congrès qui décidera
ce que j'ai entendu pour qui ce que j'ai
entendu de xavier bertrand
c'est qu'ils n'iraient pas contre cet
avenir politique je suis optimiste je
suis confiant en étant je suis réaliste
il faudra toujours qu'il ya une forte
volonté de rassemblement alors il ya un
deuxième nom on parle de xavier bertrand
mais un deuxième nom qui fait turbuler
le système comme disait jean pierre
chevènement naguère c'est eric zemmour
eric zemmour on entend qu'il pourrait
peut-être vous perturber vous gênez vous
autres les républicains alors que c'est
peut-être votre chance précisément parce
que s'il fait du mal à madame le pen
c'est peut-être une chance pour les
républicains d'être présent au deuxième
tour écoutez j'ai déjà dit je crois que
c'est elisabeth martichoux je les dis
ailleurs que je ne partageais pas les
valeurs de terri seymour je ne les
partage par et je vais prendre trois
exemples quand il s'est exprimé tout à
fait récemment sur la décision de la
famille sens de l'air de faire enterrer
des enfants
jerusalem j'avoue que d'être ces deux
femmes y avoir vécu landes râble j'avoue
je ne supporte pas et leur établissement
c'est très profond leur énervement
d'abord ma conception dont la conception
républicaine dans la déclaration oui ça
me scandalise quand je les ai entendu
quelques années parler des femmes qui a
baissé la politesse par tous les mois je
ne peux pas supporter ce genre de choses
mais en même temps voyez je fais comme
macron
phénomène zemmour ça traduit une
inquiétude renforcée et oui ça traduit
une inquiétude des français qui se
posent des questions notamment sur
l'europe identité sur des questions
qu'on n'a pas résolu la question
migratoire
la question de la sécurité il faut donc
que nous qui croyons dans un certain
nombre de valeurs zoug courage
d'apporter sur ces questions des
réponses et des réponses qui soit
efficace est clair qu at il été fait sur
la question migratoire et au cours de ce
quinquennat est ce que vous allez
oeuvrer pour qu'il essaie 500 signé
avant moi je vais vraiment souhaité
qu'ils
désireraient contre je ne fais pas ce
genre de calcul je ne partage pas ses
valeurs n'imaginais pas avoir un espèce
de calcul politique je dirai au maire
je trouve que j'en connais beaucoup et
il se trouve que j'ai des relations avec
eux marquer plus tôt par la confiance
que naturellement ça leur appartient
mais que je pense qu'il faut qu'ils
manifestent à des candidats qui portent
des valeurs qui peuvent être différentes
des miennes mais qui sont des valeurs
partagées dans la rue
c'est ce présent je trouve qu'on en
parle vraiment beaucoup ce qui démontre
qu'il est assez important qu'on ait un
ou une candidate sans trop tarder
d'accord qu'elle est si vous arrivez
dernière question un jour aux affaires
peut-être au mois d'avril la première
réforme que la droite devra engager je
pense que ça nous renvoie au débat
convient d'avoir d'abord tracer une
perspective pour les finances publiques
parce qu'on ne peut pas continuer dans
le quoi qu'il advienne que nous
évoquions et il y à quelques minutes
deuxièmement il faut reconstruire
l'unité de ce pays et reconstruire
l'unité ça passe par un certain nombre
de décisions décision de la
décentralisation
c'est à dire faire jouer c'est pas
qu'une affaire des élus qui parlent peu
et lui c'est la proximité des citoyens
qui ont le sentiment que leur vie que
les décisions ne leurs appartiennent
plus c'est la deuxième décision la
troisième décision c'est qu'il faudra
répondre à ces questions de sécurité
pourquoi pas une loi de programmation
sur la sécurité intérieure et répondent
aussi à la question migratoire nous
sommes aujourd'hui un pays qui est n'a
pas de politique en matière
d'immigration et d'ailleurs vous êtes le
la dernière je pense qu en tous les cas
il va falloir poser la question et je
pense que tu as peut réserver j'ai déjà
dit sur le mot moratoire et quand tous
les cas revisiter toute la politique
migratoire
simplement 2010 938 mille demandes
d'asile
quand dans le reste de l'europe ça
baissé de 43% est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
sujet dans notre pays ça veut pas dire
que je suis contre l'asie le contraire
c'est un droit fondamental
ce détournement parlais tout à l'heure
avec ce détournement là il fait partie
donc voilà un ensemble sûr que nous
pourrions mettre en place merci beaucoup
de questions un fondement d'une réponse
rapide sur des sujets qui sont
importants mais on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler vous avez parlé du projet de
loi de programmation sur la sécurité
mais le maquereau en allant chercher
il a eu raison elle est indispensable
au dîner d'état les moyens
donner des perspectives donc ça c'est
une question sur 9 ans claire et avant
d'accueillir nos parlementaires je
voulais vous poser une question sur un
texte qui sans doute vous est cher c'est
la décentralisation c'est jacqueline
gourault qu'il a porté pour
le gouvernement c'est un texte de
décentralisation avez-vous la garantie
gérard larcher oui donc il sera adopté
avant la fin du quinquennat je regarde
la présidente de la commission des lois
et à leur demande m'a fait savoir que
a priori les semaines des 6 et 13
décembre
seront consacrés à l'examen par
l'assemblée nationale avec je l'espère
un dialogue positif et que je souhaite
vraiment parce que c'est l'intérêt du
pays je parlais des fractures tout à
l'heure c'est pas que la
décentralisation c'est aussi la
déconcentration une autre conception de
l'état c'est aussi une forme de
simplification et puis la
différenciation est ce qu'on traite tout
le territoire de la même année donc vous
êtes confiant ça sera
avant la fin du quinquennat je l'espère
et je n'ai pas en quoi l'engagement qu'a
pris le premier ministre ne serait pas
tenue alors vous faites la transition
aussi finalement c'est le moment des
parlements leur attention
[Musique]
et vous savez jamais marché s'être
l'originalité de cette émission il ya
deux parlementaires qui vous rejoignent
et qui vont vous interpellez je vous les
présente mais vous les connaissez bien
sûr y est le broad vivait donc
présidente la république en marge de la
commission des lois et député des
yvelines vous avez choisi d'ailleurs
pour votre carte blanche on va et vient
dans quelques instants de revenir sur
une décision récente de la cour de
justice de la république pour monde a
compris et à vos côtés jean yves le
conte d'hans soir jean yves le conte
sénateurs socialistes des français de
l'étranger membres aussi de la
commission des lois donc côté senna donc
on commence si vous voulez bien madame
monsieur par les cartes blanches yale
brand peavey la cour de justice de la
république a récemment mise en examen
d'une ancienne ministre
agnès buzyn et et vous avez bas comme
d'eau que vous êtes peut-être interrogé
sur le rôle la cour de justice de la
république à cette occasion
effectivement cela pose de nombreuses
questions qui sont des questions très
compliquées la cour de justice de la
république est une institution
finalement assez récente
elle concentre beaucoup de critiques et
finalement on a le sentiment que
personne n'y trouve son compte les
citoyens ont l'impression que les
politiques jugent les politiques
les politiques considèrent que la
responsabilité des ministres doit plutôt
être engagée devant le parlement plutôt
que par des magistrats on voit que les
procédures sont très longues on peut
penser à l' affaire karachi qui a donné
lieu à la relaxe de monsieur balladur et
la condamnation de monsieur léotard
c'est plus de 20 ans d'instruction donc
on a une juridiction qui en tout cas
suscite de nombreuses critiques nous
proposions de la réforme et dans une
réforme constitutionnelle qui n'a pas
été à son terme au delà de la question
de la juridiction il allie à la question
également du chant d'engagement de la
responsabilité d'un politique finalement
est ce que une abstention doit valoir
engagements de sa responsabilité et
c'est vrai que
là les décisions récentes pose question
en tout cas on le voit bien et j'aurais
aimé avoir votre position monsieur le
président du sénat je crois savoir que
vous accompagnez la notre volonté de
réforme sur ce point lors de la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2018 est ce que
finalement c'est toujours le cas est-ce
que vous souhaitez effectivement que la
suppression pure et simple avec un
renvoi à la cour d'appel de paris où est
ce que finalement on estime que la
responsabilité doit être uniquement
politique voilà quelques questions en
tout cas qui à mon sens se pose à tout
homme et femme politique aujourd'hui
sachant que bien évidemment il n'est pas
question de revenir sur la
responsabilité d'un ministre il était
évident mais finalement que n'importe
quelle personne qui s'engage à avoir un
mandat électoral que ce soit un maire
que ce soit un conseiller départemental
ministre un parlementaire doit voir sa
responsabilité engagée si nécessaire du
fait de ses actions ça me paraît être
une évidence maintenant la question
c'est comment ce quels sont les
principes qui doivent guider alors je
dois vider cet engagement de
responsabilité
ce dossier montre une fois de plus que
nous allons progressivement vers une
pénalisation de vie politique et que
au fond cette pénalisation est en train
de remplacer la responsabilité politique
d'alors dire à ceux qui nous écoutent
il faut pas se tromper l'immunité ne
protège pas les parlementaires de rendre
des comptes devant la justice
c'est simplement dans leur acte
politique qu'on a sur leur liberté de
s'exprimer et je dois dire que cette
question aujourd'hui elle nous renvoie
une certaine conception du contrôle
et je pense que dans notre pays parce
que je vois bien la réaction de nos
concitoyens ils ont l'impression que le
contrôle ne s'exerce pas vraiment il y a
eu qu'une seule épisodes parfois ça nous
a
un peu ont pesé c'est la commission
denquête et sur la sphère alexandre
benalla qui a été conduite au sénat de
manière publique mais je pourrais
ajouter lubrizol
une véritable commission denquête je
pense qu'une des vocations du sénat dans
sa diversité c'est d'exercer ce contrôle
c'est extrêmement important alors je
vais vous dire un beau c'est que vous
avez évoqué 2018 et en 2018 c'est vrai
qu'on n'était pas loin
dans le dialogue et non pas échouer du
tout pour ça
mais il y avait eu à la suite d'une
observation du conseil d'état un article
je ne saurais plus vous le répéter
exactement mais qui
détermine et que ça n'est que dans un
cas très intentionnelle ou à défaut
qu'on pouvait mettre en cause une
décision
politique je crois que c'est extrêmement
important ce texte qui faisait suite à
l'avis du conseil d'état en l'état
actuel ça ne peut être qu'une réforme
constitutionnelle
et cette réforme constitutionnelle je
suis pas tout à fait certain aujourd'hui
que nous l'abordions totalement de la
même manière quand 2018 avec
l'expérience avec notamment une
préoccupation que j'ai
c'est la procédure d'appel éventuelle
d'une décision or il n'était pas prévu
d'appel alors qu'on en a à la pelle pour
la cour d'assises on n'avait pas un
appel pour la responsabilité des
ministres alors je voudrais dire à ceux
qui nous écoutent ne croyez pas qu'on
soit en immunité et les ministres
doivent rendre des comptes
c'est devant des comptes c'est le
contraire
ne croyez pas chaque concitoyen que les
ministres bénéficient d'une immunité
absolue est incertaine mais avec la cour
de justice c'est presque le contraire
puisque on les met en cause pour des
intentions une interprétation de leurs
actes et non pas l'heure actuelle c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'il faut
retrouver d'éclipsé
c'est guy carcassonne qui disait elle
politise le débat et le pénalise la
politique
ça ça peut être à partir de la réflexion
de guy carcassonne une réflexion pour
les échanges que nous aurons dans le
futur
question d'observation
je crois qu'il est vraiment important de
séparer la gerbe responsabilité
politique de la responsabilité pénale
voilà la réponse était politique et les
devant les électeurs et elle est devant
le parlement le cas échéant
de la même manière sur la sphère qui
nous préoccupe tous aujourd'hui en
france par rapport à une relation avec
les états unis et l'australie il ya une
responsabilité politique il ya des
choses à comprendre le parlement doit
aussi jouer son rôle dans sur ce
contrôle voilà vous l'aurez caser sa
ce que je disais de la réaction du
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées nous allons demander compte de ce
qui s'est passé jean yves le conte votre
carte blanche elle porte la politique
migratoire
alors c'est un sujet de la
présidentielle ça va beaucoup monté
oui tout à fait monsieur le président
parce que michel barnier chers collègues
a priori grand européen à semer la
consternation il ya quelques temps sur
ses prises de position sur la primauté
du droit constitutionnel et de la
constitution sur le droit européen en
matière de migration en tout cas ils
souhaitaient cela alors que on a bien vu
combien la crise migratoire de 2015 2016
a été finalement résolu par des par
l'union européenne layton plus ou moins
hypocrite mais par l'union européenne et
pas par les états nations et donc quand
on voit que finalement la france est
parmi les grands états un de ceux qui
accueillent le moins par habitant quand
on voit que
parmi les grands états qui ont des
économies fortes et des recherches
innovantes il ya beaucoup plus
finalement personnes qui sont nées hors
dehors de leur pays qu'en france
comment est-ce qu'on peut aborder
l'élection présidentielle en faisant la
course à l'échalote avec eric zemmour
sur ce sujet
écoutez je pense que michel barnier dont
chacun connaît les sentiments européen
très profond il a fait un constat
l'europe comme la france ont échoué en
matière de politique migratoire et
d'asie et d'ailleurs c'est un sujet sur
lequel j'ai échangé avec le président
châble c'était au mois de juillet à
strasbourg dans un tête à tête où il me
prédisait
la fin
de l' afghanistan tel que nous l'avions
espéré c'était un espoir très très ténus
et nous parlions de l'éventuelle
phénomène de déplacement des populations
parce que derrière le phénomène
migratoire il ya toujours des hommes des
femmes et qui vivent des drames et de
pas résoudre la question migratoire
c'est au fond continuer à fermer les
yeux sur des centaines d'hommes et de
femmes qui tous prennent haut sur les
côtes de la manche se noie ou sont en
péril de leur vie jour après jour nuit
après nuit
faut une politique migratoire
nous n'avons pas de politique migratoire
elle passe par la définition de quotas
par le parlement elle passe par une
politique d'intégration d'assimilation
ans les deux mots ne me font pas peur
qui permettent de créer cette communauté
nationale nous sommes tous les deux élu
d'un département dans lequel les
problèmes d'intégration d'assimilation
avait une vraie priorité pour former
communauté et c'est un travail sur
lequel on peut conjuguer nos efforts
alors
derrière tout cela il ya aussi
un débat qui répond à votre question
entre cour européenne des droits de
l'homme sur la question par exemple des
politiques de regroupement familial il
ya des sujets qui doivent être apportées
malaise que dit qu'est ce que dit michel
barnier qui a un sujet qui a un problème
et qu'il faut essayer de le résoudre
voilà pourquoi il propose un moratoire
pour examiner l'ensemble des
dispositions législatives le texte que
nous avons fait ensemble sur lequel le
président de la commission des lois
actuelles du sénat était le rapporteur
ça n'a pas marché nous devons avoir une
vraie
quitter le territoire français y
résident -2 13%
vous voyez bien mais
vous avez monsieur le président même le
directeur des études et des étrangers en
france nous dit que les 13% en fait
c'est par rapport au docu tf qu'on donne
et que d'autres pays pendant
obligation de quitter demandé au préfet
oui mais est-ce que quand même rappelons
le drame de nous parler des obligations
de quitter le territoire français non
exécutées va écouter enfants nous quand
vous nous parlez de plus jamais nous
parler
nous n'avons pas de marge de manoeuvre
pour avoir des marges de manoeuvre il
faudrait avoir un nombre de personnes
accueillies beaucoup plus important par
par français aujourd'hui la moitié des
personnes qui rentrent sur le territoire
qu un premier titre sont liées à des ré
pour des raisons familiales
d'après nous avons des étudiants nous
n'avons pas de marge de manoeuvre nous
n'avons pas de marge de la sauce on va
demander aux français de se marier de
donner des coteaux français pour se
marier avec des étrangers nous ne
pouvons pas réduire ce chiffre avait
bien raisonner de la même manière michel
barnier s'exprime non pas sur les
questions de la cour de la cedeao mais
dollars mais l'accord avoir robert donc
juste la cge c'était une remise en cause
profonde oui de la construction et je
pense que alors que l'union européenne a
prouvé son efficacité entre 2015 et
aujourd'hui
si elle était aussi efficace le
président choblet n'aurait pas dit qu'il
fallait trouver
la possibilité de l'asile à l'extérieur
des frontières européennes qui est un
des sujets dont je voudrais pas qu'on
qu'on se bat on à
277 milles titre de séjour qui ont été
données est-ce que c'est rien est-ce que
nous non nous devons aussi négocier avec
les pays qui émettent cette immigration
est ce que vous pensez que c'est
satisfaisant de voir ce qu'ils
continuent à se passer en méditerranée
90 mille étudiants et 90000 et de
regroupement familial dans les dents
dans plus de la moitié des conjoints de
français est-ce qu'on a beaucoup de
marge de manoeuvre et on peut avoir de
marge de manoeuvre si l'on définît je ne
dis pas non à l'immigration n'ont fait
de magny catoire je dis simplement qu'il
faut maîtriser la politique et la
politique ça appartient à l'exécutif
sous le contrôle direct au fil de l'eau
aujourd'hui on est totalement fil de
l'eau on maîtrise rien
dont on a un sujet d'intégration majeur
et je vous jure je préférerais qu'on
s'intéresse à la question de
l'intégration alors plutôt que de faire
penser qu'on a des marges de mal et où
paul mara manoeuvre si on les a c'est ce
serait des remises en cause des
étudiants se serait de remise en cause
du droit du droit à vivre en famille et
ça serait particulièrement entre eux et
je pourrai penser qu'on peut intégrer
quand dans une classe vous avez et dans
la ville 40 50 60 % des enfants qui
parlent une autre langue il faut qu'on
mesure quelle est notre capitale
mais ça ce n'est pas une question de
nombre de personnes qui migrent
dans la localisation localiser et de 2,2
millions de maîtrise en vente en ne
maîtrisant plus rien en n'ayant pas de
politique migratoire ça nous contait
aujourd'hui aux échecs nous connaisseurs
la politique migratoire que nous avons
mise en place effectivement par une loi
dite asile et immigration que vous avez
refusé c'est une des commissions mixtes
nous n'avons pas réussi à faire aboutir
ces mises en place justement avec des
schémas national d'accueil avec une
accélération massive des procédures pour
justement que l'asile soient reconnus ou
soit rejeter il est faux de dire que les
occuper de tf ne sont pas exécutées nous
avons programmé les obligations
n'étaient le territoire nous avons fait
un effort majeur avec les pays qui
doivent les réceptionner pour que ceux
ci délivre ce qu'on appelle des laissez
passer et vous savez que c'est compliqué
mais cette action elle est menée par
gérald darmanin de façon extrêmement
massive et puis nous avons voté très
récemment une loi très importante sur
l'aide au développement pour que
justement la réponse de serre des pays
qui sont ou le porteur d'immigration
soit lui également très augmentée afin
justement de s'attaquer à la 10 au
problème à la racine mais en revanche il
ne faut en aucun cas revenir sur nos
engagements internationaux sur la
tradition d'accueil et d'asile de notre
territoire dont j'ai béni répondons ma
famille a bénéficié dans le temps et qui
je le crois fait l'honneur de notre
république madame la présidente il n'est
pas question pour moi
d'avoir une image de mon pays fermé ou
de l'europe fermé mais nous ne
maîtrisons pas ces politiques et ça nous
conduit il comprit à avoir ces mineurs
étrangers qui sont dans des situations
extrêmement difficiles
j'ai souvenir ya pas longtemps à cahors
de voir ces jeunes accueillis dans des
foyers et qui toute la journée et ray
dans une ville au milieu du département
du lot et la réalité c'est qu'il faut
avoir les moyens de l'accueil de
l'intégration de l'assimilation or ça ne
se décline pas avec des chiffres que
nous sommes incapables d'assimiler vous
savez bien aujourd'hui sur des mineurs
étrangers un certain nombre de
départements sont totalement débordés
dépassés et que nous le faisons pas
valeur valoir les valeurs humaines que
vous évoquez est que nous avons en
partage j'en suis certain tous les trois
il faut regarder les choses en face je
disais tout à l'heure vous avez vu ce
que j'ai dit sur monsieur zemmour je ne
suis pas suspect d'avoir une affection
quelconque c'est parce qu'il faut
répondre aux préoccupations des français
non pas d'une manière populiste
mais en vérité est en vérité nous avons
un problème migratoire
positions populistes
c'est une approche qui nous permet de
nous donner le temps d'apporter des
réponses je ne crois pas que fermer
notre pays à double tour soit une
approche qui nous permettent de gagner
alors je pense qu'il faut et reste
ce ne serait pas ma volonté non plus dit
mais reste trois minutes oui c'est très
peu pendant des questions extrêmement
large mais on avait choisi vous avez
choisi comme questions communes sur fond
de crise démocratique le déficit ou la
frustration des français en terme de
représentativité une réforme qu'il
faudrait faire pour améliorer cette
représentativité au parlement et la
réponse très brève devient larcher yezh
bro pvc très difficile minutes parce que
les les réformes des personnels nous
passionne non à la commission des lois
est voué à votre votre fonction non moi
je prends je proposais en réformes
institutionnelles à mons 2 cumulé les
élections présidentielle et législatives
de telle sorte que il y ait moins de
subordination dans l'élection des
parlementaires à l'élection
présidentielle si elle se tenait le même
jour c'est une idée que je proposais
parler d'autres mais il y en a une
multitude est la vôtre pas sur les rangs
oui croyez vous qu'il faille faire plus
de démocratie participative à chaque
fois que des sujets de cette nature sont
arrivés jusqu'à la hausse aidé à la
majorité c'est nationale les a refusées
alors que nous avons aujourd'hui des
outils numériques qui permettent de
mieux faire participer les citoyens tout
en laissant le pouvoir après au
parlement dans ta question passionnante
à la fois répondre brièvement vous
réponds plate forme plate forme
numérique que le sénat mis en place pour
la relation avec les élus que nous
allons étendre à l'ensemble des citoyens
et je crois et j'ai rencontré le nouveau
président du conseil économique social
et environnemental que je connais bien
est elle qui je fais confiance et je
pense que c'est dans cet échange que
nous pourrons avancer sur la
participation je crois aussi à la
démocratie participative sur le terrain
gelé pratiquer comme mère elle est utile
mais je pense ça me renvoie à votre
observation que la crise de la
représentation si au fond une crise de
confiance très profonde je ne suis pas
certain que ça soit les inversions de
calendrier qui change quoi que ce soit
en fait nous avons depuis dix années une
crise des résultats entre les
engagements qui sont pris et les
résultats ressenti par les citoyens
voilà pourquoi je crois qu'il faut qu'on
retrouve le chemin de la confiance voilà
pourquoi je pense qu'il ne faut pas que
l'élection présidentielle soit
l'occasion de faire des propositions qui
soient j'allais dire dont chiffre est
non réalisable voilà pourquoi il faut
regarder les choses en vérité et je le
dis vraiment très sincèrement cette
élection doit être l'occasion de renouer
avec la confiance dans ce pays cette
crise de confiance les très très profond
dans l'oubli à lord s'est terminée
pardon merci beaucoup d'amour à tous les
deux d'avoir
encore quelques temps on va retourner si
vous voulez bien on va retourner
au figaro lac pour rejoindre vincent
roux qui encore une question pour vous
j'ai un marché qui ya un sondage qui
vous a frappé sur lequel vous vouliez
interpol y est aussi gérard larcher
vincent oui elisabeth au lendemain
d'ailleurs delà du premier tour de la
primaire europe ecologie les verts qui a
réuni plus d'électeurs que lors des
scrutins du même type précédent selon un
sondage doxa bakbone pour le figaro 55%
des français ont une bonne opinion
d'europe écologie les verts il pense que
c'est un parti utile est ce que c'est
votre avis jarlard chez moi je crois que
la question climatique environnementale
et d'aujourd'hui très largement partagé
elle est une préoccupation
exprimée par l'ensemble de nos eaux de
nos compatriotes que c'est donc un sujet
quand ils ont le sentiment et c'est
d'ailleurs en partie vrai qu'elle peut
être porté par un parti politique mais
l'écologie ne peut pas être confisqué
par un seul parti politique je crois que
nous partageons dans les différentes
formations politiques parfois des
niveaux différents ces préoccupations
environnementales et climatiques et que
ses préoccupations environnementales et
climatiques nous ont conduit d'ailleurs
à
converger sur la loi qui m'a résilience
juste avant l'été sans rejeter la
réforme constitutionnelle c'est autre
chose la réforme constitutionnelle nous
l'avons rejetée parce que c'est à nous
de faire la constitution et de ne pas
déléguer au travers du mot garantie de
pouvoir constituant à d'autres voilà
merci beaucoup vincent euros on vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine mercier
elle vivait merci beaucoup sénateurs le
compte merci l'an passé sept heures avec
nous sur lcp et public sénat dans
audition publique est très bonne semaine
bien sûr en suivant les deux chaînes
parlementaires à lundi prochain 19h30 25
[Musique]